we turned out at Texas today and search  teams at Fort Hood have now found human  remains as they investigate the  disappearance of a soldier the remains  have not yet been identified but the  family of Vanessa Guillen believe it is  their daughter she was last seen in  April her family suspects her  disappearance is tied to alleged sexual  harassment now they are calling for a  congressional investigation this is a  national security issue national  security if we're losing our soldiers  here not because of Isis not because of  terrorism but because of domestic  terrorism on our bases and cover-ups by  commands earlier this morning a soldier  from Fort Hood committed suicide gans  sister said she actually spoke to that  soldier before about her sister and she  says he laughed in her face the family  believes that soldier and others may  have played a role in Vanessa's  disappearance